l'article canadienne a jamais été aussi
accessible le nombre de voyages sur ces
eaux à triplés depuis 30 ans mais la
frontière canadienne dans la région elle
n'a jamais été aussi vulnérable si il y
a des actions immédiates qui ne sont pas
prises qu'il va avoir des lacunes très
importantes dans la surveillance et la
capacité de répondre aux urgences dans
l'article dans la prochaine décennie le
problème c'est que les équipements
actuels arriveront à la fin de leur vie
utile d'ici 10 ans et que les nouveaux
ne seront pas livrés à temps pour
prendre le relais ainsi le Canada risque
de se retrouver à découvert à plusieurs
reprises au cours de la prochaine
décennie c'est le cas de la surveillance
par radar le système radar sat a été
conçu pour fonctionner jusqu'en 2026
après quoi sa performance va se dégrader
mais on s'attend ce que le système qui
va le remplacer soit opérationnel
seulement en 2035
même chose pour les aéronefs Aurora la
flotte de 14 appareils a été modernisée
pour prolonger sa durée de vie jusqu'en
2030 mais le premier appareil de
nouvelles génération d'aéronef ne sera
pas livré avant 2032 puis sur la mer la
situation n'est pas plus rassurante du
la vérification générale ce qu'on a
constaté maintenant dans les eaux
articles c'est que les retards ont
continué et que la marge de manœuvre
vraiment elle est presque disparue et si
le temps de vraiment prendre des actions
pour s'assurer qu'il y ait pas des
lacunes importantes dans la surveillance
de l'article
le ministre des Transports prend acte du
rapport et assure que le gouvernement a
augmenté la cadence des investissements
dans l'Arctique
le monde a changé que le Canada a besoin
d'identifier les nouvelles technologies
à déployer pour s'assurer de bien
protéger les eaux articles si la
cicatrice générale évoque des risques de
failles dans les moyens utilisés pour
assurer la protection dans l'article le
chef d'état-major de l'armée canadienne
lui s'inquiète des conséquences le
général Wayne hair a réitéré il y a
quelques semaines que le Canada ne
pouvait pas ignorer que sa souveraineté
soit éventuellement contestée dans la
région par des pays comme la Russie ou
la Chine le cas échéant a-t-il rappelé
la présence militaire est aussi très
limitée ici Valérie Gamache Radio-Canada
Ottawa